American Horror Story is back with its
100th episode and it seems like only
yesterday we were roaming the halls of
Murder House we're gonna jump right into
this preview so as always if you haven't
seen it yet I've left a link in the
description but please come back I'm so
very lonely the preview begins with a
ton of quick shots of past season
celebrating its 100th episode now I'm
not gonna get into all of them or I'd be
here all day so we're just gonna jump
right into this shot of Richard Ramirez
now we can't be 100% sure if this
happens before or after he and jingles
have left camp redwood but judging by
where he's positioned in the neighbor in
the hallway wearing a nightgown it looks
like she could be asking the wrong guy
to turn down the music now here is where
we get into the good stuff Ghost Montana
having been killed by Brooke last
episode tans on the dock and I guess
ghosts can tan well an adventuring
cameraman stumbles upon her the
boathouse in the back has the words keep
out so it looks like camp redwood is now
abandoned the question is how much time
has passed since the events of episode 5
are we still in the 80s or have we
perhaps fast forwarded several years the
camera guy does look like he could be as
far forward as the 90s but we'll have to
stay tuned to find out Montana and
Xavier have embraced their evil ways
Montana kills the camera guy and Xavier
this random woman saying being bad feels
good notice also the tent in the
background here so it looks like our
dead counselors stalk anyone who comes
on to the campgrounds so that tent is
likely owned by some unsuspecting
campers that will get killed by them and
it looks like Ray's the only one who
still has somewhat of a conscience
saying you can't kill every single
person that wanders through here why and
that's pretty much it for this week's
episode they usually give us more to
work with in the previews but my guess
is that next episode is a big change
from what we've been used to so they're
running to keep most of it a bit of a
surprise for the actual show thanks
again for watching make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and leave your theories about
what will happen next episode in the
comments below you can also reach me on
twitter at things story
yt until next time remember daddy loves
you very much